" Le projet de loi que
je vous présente est exceptionnel.
Je vous propose en effet
d’instaurer la démocratie à l’école.
Nous représentons 98%
de la nation scolaire,
mais nous sommes
le tiers état de l’école. "
Le Parlement des enfants
c’est une journée absolument magique,
j’allais dire pour les enfants
comme pour les adultes.
Tout est fait pour
que l’Assemblée nationale
le temps d’une journée
devienne un paradis pour les enfants.
" Alors dans les jardins de Lassay,
il y a pas mal de stands
beaucoup de choses à manger.
C’est un peu
Charlie et la chocolaterie ici. "
Ils vont avoir la chance
de visiter l’Assemblée nationale
d’être l’espace d’une journée
de vrais petits députés.
" - Questions pour un député!
Comment s’appelle le Président
de l’Assemblée nationale?
" Claude Bartolone!
Combien il y a de députés
dans l’Assemblée nationale?
577! "
Le but évidemment, c’est de
sensibiliser tous les petits élèves de CM2
à la question de la citoyenneté,
à la démocratie.
" - Nous allons examiner
les 4 propositions de loi
sélectionnées par le jury national.
- Je représente la classe
de Chappes dans l’Aube
et nous sommes honorés
de défendre notre proposition de loi.
- La proposition de loi de ma classe
traite de la violence scolaire
un sujet universel!
- Nous voudrions que les adultes
nous aident à ce que tous
dès le plus jeune âge
comprenions mieux les différences
entre filles et garçons
et que nous soyons ainsi
réellement égaux en droits
et que nous ayons
accès aux mêmes chances.
- J’en appelle donc à vous,
écoliers de France!
Si vous aimez la démocratie,
il est de votre devoir
de soutenir ce projet de loi.
Votez pour la proposition de loi n°2,
je vous en remercie. "
Ce n’est pas du théâtre.
Les enfants travaillent vraiment
au cours de l’année scolaire de CM2
et déposent véritablement un texte.
Et s’il est valable, s’il peut s’intégrer
dans un texte de loi dans un article
et bien ça arrive
et c’est arrivé à 4 reprises
au cours des 23 dernières éditions
du Parlement des enfants.
" Est arrivé en première position
avec 269 voix
la proposition de loi n°3
visant à prévenir... "
Le génie de LCP ça a été
d’en faire un évènement télévisuel.
C’est un véritable exercice
d’éducation civique, en live!